so it appears that a fan may have
recently discovered the final Easter egg
in guardians of the galaxy for those of
you who aren't aware of what I'm talking
about there were many Easter eggs placed
in guardians of the galaxy there are
actually more than 50 Easter eggs in the
movie but there is one that has not been
discovered yet many fans have thought
they have discovered the final Easter
egg but James Gunn the director has come
out on Twitter and told them each that
they are wrong so what is the final
Easter egg and guardians of the galaxy
one fan thinks they figured it out
before we get started be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on everything that's
happening in the MCU so this theory
states that Galactus is actually the
final Easter egg it takes place when the
collector is explaining to the guardians
what the Infinity stones are he
particularly focuses on the power stone
a bunch of images flash on the screen
but it shows a planet and that planet
could be - uh which is the home of Galan
now in the comics after the Big Bang
ghal and evolves and took a lactis and
he does this by merging with the
sentence of the universe and it just so
happens that one of the images that the
collector shows is a face that looks
just like de sentience of the universe
in the comics the synth Ian's of the
universe has a purple color and has the
same facial expression as the face
that's shown and not to mention the
celestial that destroys the planet has a
staff and that staff head looks just
like Galactus his helmet the theory goes
even further and says that in the comics
Galan is saved by a voice and so is
Peter quill and guardians of the galaxy
when Gamora calls to him so this theory
certainly makes sense and everything
seems to add up could this be the final
Easter egg that hasn't been found in
guardians of the galaxy director James
Gunn is pretty good at jumping on social
media and shutting down these theories
so let's hope he gets on social media
soon and tells us if we found it or not
but in the meantime what do you all
think could this be the final Easter egg
of guardians of the galaxy let me know
your thoughts in the comments below hit
the like button before you
and be sure to subscribe to my channel
so you can stay up to date on everything
Marvel DC and superhero thank you so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]